[Musique]
justin pamphile bonjour bonjour monsieur
livory bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première vous êtes le
maire du lorrain depuis 2008 vous avez
vous présenté donc pour la troisième
fois vous avez 51 50 ans et vous allez
conduire la liste du rassemblement des
forces l'eau rhinoise
qu'est ce qui vous motive encore
qu'est-ce que pourquoi vous présentez
bah écoutez c'est simplement c'est là
l'idée que quand on est au travail que
le travail que l'on fait a du sens mais
il faut à la fois le poursuivre
simplement et puis autour de moi j'ai
une équipe avec laquelle je travaille
qui me montre tous les jours que ce que
nous faisons avec la population a du
sens et puis celle surtout leur taux que
nous avons de la population et qui nous
encourage à poursuivre et à faire en
sorte que le travail de renouvellement
de reconstruction de requalification et
de construction que nous menons a du
sens et qu'il faut par conséquent
accentuer la troisième candidature au
sens où vous la présente est une
candidature qui a vocation justement à
accentuer ce travail là si vous êtes élu
dans qu'en 2020 safra 18 ans à la tête
de la ville est ce que vous pensez déjà
la relève
écoutez je ne vais pas vous cacher que
j'ai toujours dit aux élus j'ai toujours
dis à la population que je ne passerais
pas toute ma vie à faire de la politique
parce que je crois que la tendance
nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est pas celle qui
a existé par le passé vous aviez des
mères qui restent à quasiment 35 40 ans
dans une posture politique et dans une
responsabilité politique et qui
quelquefois gréve m je dirais
l'émergence de nouvelles générations
ce ne sera pas mon cas et les l'ensemble
des colistiers avec lesquels je
travaille depuis quelques années le
savent pas ce que je lui ai toujours dit
publiquement en tout cas on l'aurait ça
veut dire quoi ce sera pas votre cas les
trois quatre cinq mandats
non non ça mais je pense que vous n'avez
qu'à 50 ans il est encore jeune
politique mais on peut accéder à
d'autres responsabilités mais je reste
persuadé que le mandat de maire et
amanda exigeant c'est un mandat qui qui
demande à la fois de la disponibilité
qui demande de je dirais une présence
permanente et parfois ça peut être un
mandat usant et ceux et celles qui se
sont installés peut être quelquefois
dans un petit confort peuvent aller
jusqu'à cinq six mandats je ne conçois
pas les choses comme ça je conçois ce
mandat comme étant un mandat actif où on
doit permanence considéré jeudi que les
éléments de la construction et par
conséquent sa demande d'une énergie
constante
alors quelles sont les grandes lignes
quels sont les grands axes de votre
programme
aujourd'hui je vais pas aborder les
grands axes en tout cas vous dire
simplement déjà la satisfaction que nous
avons du travail accompli que ce soit
sur le tissu associatif les éléments
économiques avec les agriculteurs en
matière de logement nous avons également
travaillé énormément sur nous avons nos
différentes infrastructures sur
l'assainissement la voirie
aujourd'hui je pense que nous allons
poursuivre dans l'esprit dans lequel
nous avons entamé cette mandature en
2014 et faire en sorte que nous allons
maintenant enclenchée sur de nouveaux
champs et un nouveau chantier et ce
nouveau chantier là c'est un chant ty
c'est le chantier de ce que j'appelle du
développement et de la mise en oeuvre de
d'opérations qui ont vocation à
structurer sur le territoire du
développement et à vendre la ville
beaucoup plus attractive et je mexplique
rapidement sans rentrer dans les détails
je rappelle pour les uns et les autres
que le schéma de cohérence territoriale
qui était votée à cap nau martinique
place la ville du lorrain comme étant
une ville centrale c'est un bassin de
vie de l'ordre de 25 mille habitants par
conséquent si nous sommes bassin de vie
de 25 mille habitants mais il nous faut
tenir ce rang là et faire en sorte que
le veau infrastructures soient adaptés à
ce bassin de vie là d'accord alors
comment mener à bien ce programme icc
ses orientations avec lydie mire la
diminution 10,2
dotation comment c'est ce que je vous
dis c'est à dire que la question de la
dotation la diminution de la dotation
nous oblige sans cesse à faire preuve d'
une gymnastique de en matière de gestion
pour à la fois réduire les charges
dégager de nouvelles recettes faire en
sorte que nous puissions créer du
développement faire en sorte que les
entreprises et que les personnes
puissent à la fois trouver du travail
alors le territoire nord est un
territoire complexe dans son dans sa
réalité et par conséquent le maire avec
son équipe doit en permanence chercher
de nouvelles ressources chercher les
subventions auprès des différents
partenaires et faire en sorte que le
développement se poursuivre dernière
question il reste à peine 20 secondes la
chambre régionale des comptes de en
octobre 2008 vous avez un anglais 2018
pardon sur la gestion de la caisse des
écoles 10 ans dit que les mesures de
redressement était insuffisante
c'est une affaire qui est aujourd'hui
rentré dans l'ordre la villa à régler
cette situation et la caisse
progressivement retrouver une situation
normale
donc il n'y a pas de difficultés en la
matière la villa a fait ce qu'il fallait
en terme de solidarité avec la caisse
des écoles
justin pamphile je vous remercie c'est
moi bonne journée